victorine bon sens base yahi linda
pascaline nizeyimana étudiante en droit
à l'université de montréal écoute avec
admiration qu et angie brad jackson la
première femme noire à devenir juge à la
cour suprême des etats unis c'est
tellement une fierté de voir une femme
noire comme toi d'être grand-père au
plus haut tribunal du pays et que c'est
vraiment une source d'inspiration
cette page d'histoire qui s'écrit au sud
de la frontière canadienne est victor &
nash a c'est le syndrome d'imposteurs
qu'elle ressent parfois au sein de la
faculté de droit où tu vois une personne
qui est comme toi qui es nominant la
cour suprême ok donc je mérite d'être là
je m étais très fier et je mérite
étudiant tant que tout montre les
accomplissements de gaieté angie brad
jackson inspire aussi les futurs avocate
à élargir leurs horizons professionnels
est ce que ça me tente de devenir juge
est ce que s'est passé pour moi de
m'être fait que c'est sûr que c'est des
questions que au départ j'avais pas dans
ma tête parce que j'osais pas
nécessairement penser à ça
aucune femme noire n'a brisé ce plafond
de verre à la cour suprême du canada et
la plupart des provinces canadiennes ne
sont pas en mesure de confirmer leur
nombre dans leurs tribunaux respectifs
au québec marie hélène dubé est devenu
le mois dernier la deuxième femme noire
nommée juge à la cour supérieure du
québec après sa collègue guylène beaugé
en 2007 c'est la fierté patricia
fourcand première femme noire avocate
nomi associés dans un grand cabinet
national au québec croit que la
magistrature doit refléter la population
il faut cette diversité de points de vue
pour pouvoir rendre une justice qui est
autre que perçu promettant équitable
patricia fourcand souhaite que kenji
blanc jack sin fasse sentir son
influence même si ces positions ne
seront pas majoritaires je pense que
c'est important qu'elles qu'elles
prennent le temps d'écrire décidant ce
qu'ils vont faire je l'espère faire
évoluer la cause de la diversité de
l'antiracisme ici comme aux états unis
kitengie brown jackson pourra compter
sur l'appui symbolique de femmes qu'elle
a inspiré ici valérie michaela bayne
radio-canada m'ont rien